moving on to the second we live on
aronia
please pawn to e4 he's recently
preferred pawn to e4 against carlson
they've had some debates
in these two knight c6 russell limo
lines but this time around
carlson plays d6 sorry please one of the
sidelines he's been
dabbling in g6
and d3 he likes to set up with bishop e3
followed by knight b2 which does not
look like it should put that much
pressure on black
but everyone likes playing it
magnus carlsen chooses one of his
favorite setups pawns on e5
and c5 he likes to build
the v in the center
v like vendetta for the champions chess
tour
and feels comfortable in these
structures
a3 he goes a5 also instructive not the
prettiest move in the world
just trying to stop b4 if at all
possible
and aronian now goes for the opening of
the center with pawn to
d4 custom has quite a few ways to react
edc
d5 looks good e5 the knight to t4 knight
to e4
you could also just take on d4 knight
takes d4 or k8
looks like pretty good position for
black
i hate you sometimes saying why this
caster give me
asmr vips couldn't have said it better
i'm glad you're enjoying the show i hate
you sometime
magnus does he hate his position
we do not know
rookie 8 i like d5
let's see cd 94 okay
looks pretty good as well knight g4 is
mentioned in chat but it looks somewhat
loose bishop g5 i don't think we're
going to go f6 then
yeah he takes in rookie 8 this is
another or i'm assuming okay
another pretty standard way to play the
position
targeting the pawn f3 there's all kinds
of tactics d5 or knight t5
doesn't look great so aronian chooses
not to defend the port because rook c1
f94 bishop t4 knight e4
it's unclear why it's certainly not
better it's unclear if he has enough
compensation for the pawn
i guess he does knight c4
then go after these weakened squares but
certainly no worries whatsoever
for mr carlson or the opening this time
around
gnome addict is asking how many games
they play they play
first to four and a half if that makes
sense
i think it makes sense in case of a
four-four tie
there will be two more games played then
if it's 5-5
there's armageddon those are the rules
i didn't make them but
i like the format it's fast-paced
three plus two only one match at a time
i like that they didn't have the
semi-files at the same time
so we can more or less try to follow the
edge
trolling on cod glad to have you here
saying magnus at the norwegian state
house meeting with the prime minister
no he's in pamplona he's in the room
that ernest hemingway used to write in
giving that room the gift of chess so
knight c4 played bishop v6 knight b6
bishop d4 queen d4
did he go knight c5 is an a8 hanging ah
he wants knight b3
tactics all kinds of intermediate moves
here knight to
knight takes a8 knight to b3 the queen
would have to go somewhere then knight
takes c1
this bishop would be under attack so he
would have time to recapture the pawn
i'm not sure if black is better at the
end of all these all these things
but magnus
showing he's in shape today
spotting all kinds of tricks very very
quickly
and elegant is saying first to six and a
half is preferable to me
but this is awesome as well i have
another idea elegant
what about first to eight and a half
queens exchanged no knight's exchange
pawn d6 falls
looks equal aronian
get his pawn back
there's nothing wrong with the black
position
going to f4
kings have quite f6 for example but yeah
you can do anything
on zombo comb he goes bishop b3 just
stabilizing
draw has to be the favorite here then
again we've seen from both these players
that they like to play the positions out
and with limited time
with loose pieces targets
there's still room for mistakes
tom lab is saying first to seven and a
half i like your thinking there
tom lip and i still prefer first to
eight and a half
but i think first to seven and a half is
better than first to six
queen e5 plate queen d2
covering the porn aronia does not want
to exchange queens
king g7 always useful to have the king
on the same diagonal as the queen i
don't know if that's a ruler just made
it up
but at least it can't get checked so
easily here rook is six
now our onion says okay enough messing
around let's exchange queens
thousand will take a4 he will try to
target b2
but i do not think
he's gonna get there
hashtag b2 looks
easy enough to defend can you have y
should be two
point f4 and here
here came the rook
the elegant ilk is saying why are you
dissing my six and a half idea i'm not
dissing it one bit
just saying we could take that concept
even further
chad keeps talking about the room
magnusson
let's not hit the sleeping room of his
condo he's in the
grand hotel la perla in pamplona
because this
is a pamplonia event pamplona
city in spain known
for its bull running bull fighting
not today today there is chess fighting
and magnus carson gives up a pawn tries
to activate the rook
he really really wants to get to this b2
board
should not change anything about the
outcome
check king f6 rook c7 whoa rook c7
is that turning the tables he could have
gone c6 through k6
but now is carlson first to to get to
this point
i got a little excited not sure if you
could tell by my face
because the engine bar went all the way
down
and there it goes again carson picks up
the pawn live on shaking his head
something's going wrong
now
this is probably winning it's one of
these situations
these three versus two were okay this is
just it
the textbook tactic a2 came over